hey everybody and welcome back to the
Channel first of all thank you for
30,000 subscribers means a lot to me uh
would not be here without all of your
hard work watching these videos so again
thank you a lot uh second of all I am
getting ever closer to the follower
count of this one influencer girl who
rejected me a couple years back uh so my
revenge plot is almost done I can
finally text her and uh tell her how
much better I am than her uh but we
still have to keep grinding for a few
more years to get there so let's keep
going today we'll be talking about
distrib deed
locking Okay cool so I'm going to try
and get through this one relatively
quickly as I have a NYX playoff game to
watch and it is a big season that we've
got here so first off uh the main thing
to note with this video is that it's
mostly going to be synthesis I'm not
really going to be introducing any new
Concepts to the 2.0 Series in this video
I'm just going to be uh trying to tie a
lot of them together and we're going to
be doing so in terms of building out a
distributed lock so what is a
distributed lock for those of you who do
do not know let's imagine that we have
node one over here so that's one server
we've got node two over here what we
would want to use a distributed lock for
is to basically uh avoid them both
writing to some third party resource at
the same time and uh corrupting it right
so for example if we have some document
in S3 and uh I can basically read that
document and write an extra line to it
uh if we're both writing that extra line
at the same time maybe S3 doesn't have
the proper locking protection that we
need we could corrupt that file we want
to make sure that we have mutual
exclusivity and so we do is we make this
other service which is a lock such that
only one node can grab it at a time the
other one is rejected and then the other
one is eventually going to have to come
back when that lock is released let's go
ahead and formalize that so basically we
want to build some lock that multiple
different nodes so literally different
physical computers can use to ensure
Mutual exclusion and the idea here is
that we want it to be functional in the
event of Hardware failures it's not
enough for me to just have a single note
and be like okay you guys can reach out
to this thing via rest and point and
whoever gets their first wins we need
this thing to be fault tolerant like any
other system that we're planning on
building the reason for that is that a
lot of our uh servers are going to
potentially be relying on this for a
particular lock we can have up to a 100
nodes that may be trying to grab it at
the same time now admittedly this
capacity estimate is not really going to
come into play too much during the
course of this video uh but more from an
abstract perspective we want to talk
about how to make sure that we're not
having all hundred of those computers
competing with one another at the same
time and causing a ton of load on that
distributed block cool so the first
thing that we're going to be talking
about is consistency this's going to be
a lot of database theory in this video
so it should be a nice throwback to all
of these concept videos so whatever we
do need to build has to be strongly
consistent it has to the reason I say
that is this right let's say we've got
guy over here trying to grab the lock
and our lock looks something like this
where we've got a leader and a follower
so in the first step we grab our lock we
get our lock in step two and then in
step three guy on the right also wants
this lock goes ahead and does that from
the follower right so he says o follower
has anyone grabbed the lock follower
says no go ahead and then in fact you
can have it as well so now this guy
thinks he is the lock because he saw
that no one else grabbed it and so
because this is happening uh
asynchronously right this replication
step here is actually happening in step
five it is possible now that both of
these guys think that they have the lock
they're both going to write to S3 and
now we have a problem in our hands so
again anything involving stale reads is
not going to do it for us we need
linearizable reads and we need to be
able to avoid two people writing to the
same service at the same
time cool so now that we've covered that
it also happens to be the case that
simply avoiding stale reads is not
enough right so let's imagine this guy
right here this middle node is our
distributed lock we've got both of these
clients who want to be grabbing the
distributed lock and here is the event
of steps that may happen in Step One the
guy on the left is going to uh ask for
the distributed lock and it gets granted
it in step two in step three it's going
to go through a long garbage collection
process now if you're familiar with the
Java language you might know that
depending on the garbage implementation
algorithm that you're using or the sorry
the garbage collection algorithm that
you're using uh it can actually
literally stop everything in that
program it could be a stop the world
process pause and so this guy might look
to be completely dead for a few seconds
at a time so much so that in step four
uh our distributed lock says you know
what I think this note is dead I have to
expire this lock now you might say to
yourself well this could be solved if we
just never expired locks unless the
client said to unlock it however that's
infeasible right this guy could go down
I might take a hammer to it or nuke it
or something like that and so at the end
of the day we do eventually want to have
a TTL on all of these grabs of the lock
cool so this guy expires and all of a
sudden the distributed lock says hey you
can grab me again so client number two
comes along and does the same exact
thing in steps five and six in Step
seven client number two is going to
write uh S3 and then in Step eight
client number one finishes its garbage
collection says huh nothing's changed on
my end I still have the lock wres to
S3 that would be bad so we can't be
having that so what do we do we
Implement something known as fencing
tokens so in a fencing token what we
basically do is we assign every single
grab of the lock some sort of increasing
sequence number right so let's just do
monotonically increasing for now such
that let's say you know client one gets
the fencing token 15 since client 2 is
the next guy to grab the lock he will
have the fencing token 16 and when he
writes to S3 he'll tell S3 hey I'm
writing with fencing token 16 what this
does is it ensures us that if client one
comes back along and tries to write at
the same time as fencing token 16 we're
going to say ooh you know what this
token is smaller than a token that I've
seen before we're not going to accept
your right you're just going to have to
let this one go and then all of a sudden
we're good to go right so we're never
going to basically be moving backwards
in time we shouldn't have previous
Grabbers of the lock uh writing to our
service after they've been given that
approval and you know having it revoked
as
well cool the next thing that we're
going to be talking about is single
leiter replication could we build out a
distributed lock using single liter
asynchronous replication well as I
mentioned pretty much right off the bat
no because of uh eventual consistency
but uh let's cover another problem that
uh we can deal with because in this one
you might say oh well you know we're
going to have eventual consistency
reading from the replica however what if
we both wrote and uh wrote to and read
from the leader exclusively so the
question is does this work uh in my case
I'm going to say no so like I mentioned
if we want to build this thing in a
fault tolerant manner we do ultimately
need replicas right it's not enough to
just have one node we're going to have
to store this data in multiple places
because I can take a hammer to that
leader so let's look at the following
scenario in Step One the guy on the left
is grabbing the lock gets assigned to
fencing token of 15 in step three the
leader goes down oh no but this is
asynchronous replication so we got
unlucky with our timing and all of a
sudden the process of me telling the
follower that the guy on the left has
the lock doesn't actually go through now
all of a sudden we have a bad failover
condition so when we fail over right
which is basically promoting a follower
to the next leader that's going to
happen in step four over here our
follower becomes the leader we're now
going to grab the lock on this follower
node which was never aware of the
original lock grab and so this guy is
now going to say hey buddy you've got a
fencing token of 15 right so now both of
these guys have the same exact fencing
token and both of them can go to S3 with
the same fencing token and S3 thinks
that all of those rights are coming from
the same place and as a result is going
to get corrupted right because now
they're writing to that same file and
that is bad so basically what this tells
us is that a single leader replication
even when completely uh writing to and
reading from the leader is still not
going to work because in the failover
scenario we can lose rights right this
is not perfect it is not completely
strongly consistent so we're susceptible
to failures now are there cases where
this might be sufficient for your
service I'm sure there are but the point
is we want to build something that is
not susceptible to failure uh whereas
the above system was cool another option
is that you do the same exact thing
however all of a sudden now instead of
asynchronously replicating you replicate
synchronously obviously this isn't going
to work right so if if I'm the this guy
on the left over here and for me to grab
the lock I also have to write to this
guy over here and this guy over here and
then that comes back to this guy over
here and then that goes back to the
client that doesn't work because now all
of a sudden if one of these guys breaks
no rights can be propagated because
we're basically waiting on all of them
to get propagated around the system uh
before we complete a right so in the
event that any node goes down uh
everything stops no more rights can be
done so we have no fall tolerance so
synchronous replication as per usual is
not going to work very
well now let's start getting into other
forms of replication the one that I'm
going to talk about here is Quorum
consistency so the reason that I talk
about it is because there is a pretty
common misconception that when you use
quorums like in Cassandra they are
strongly consistent now is this actually
true I'm going to go ahead and say no so
let's talk about why as a quick reminder
what are quorums let's say we're using
some type of database where all of the
nodes can be written to right every
single node is considered a leader and
let's imagine that there are n of them
in the example below n is equal to 3 so
if I'm a client and I write to W nodes
and then every single time I read I read
from R nodes and W + r is greater than N
I can actually guarantee that whatever I
write will be seen by any reader right
so let's do an example of that quickly
here's my writer over here in the
scenario W is equal to two meaning that
I have to write to two nodes at once
from my right to be considered
successful on the client so I write to
both of these guys and I hear
acknowledgements from both of these guys
and so the client says okay my right was
successful here's another client over
here reading from two nodes because R is
also equal to two and so you know that
in a cluster of size three if I write to
two nodes and then I read from two nodes
whatever two nodes that I pick out of
that cluster are inherently going to
overlap and then I'm going to see the
written key right so in this case this
node is is being written to x = 5 this
guy is being written to xal 5 maybe the
previous value of x was three right as
is shown in this old node that we didn't
write to but when we read we have to
pick two of them so in this case we're
going to pick the right nodes over here
and so actually every single time you
make a write you can take a version
number for that key and increment it so
if xal 3 was version one xal 5 is going
to be version 2 x = 5 is going to be
version two and then when this guy over
here performs a read you're going to see
that x = 5 is version 2 of that key xal
3 is version one of that key and so
we're going to say oh well clearly this
is xal 5 right xal 3 was an old value
that we just don't happen to uh have
gotten the proper new value for on that
particular node that I read
from cool so you may think to yourself
oh well this is strongly consistent
there's no way that I can perform a
right and someone else can read uh from
that same cluster and not see my right
now you're correct however there are
edge cases with quorums that make them
very imperfect so for starters let's
look at the scenario when a WR fails we
can't always roll it back right so again
I have all of the sequence numbers
written down step one is that this guy
is going to say hey I'm client a over
here I'm grabbing the lock so now this
node is going to say okay I agree that a
has the lock now what's going to happen
in step two it also wants to write to
this guy over here right because this is
a cluster of size three um aquarum we
are going to need need to write to two
places in this case and so our second
write unfortunately is going to fail so
this does not work as you can see I have
my X here so this guy this node is going
to stay as null for the lock value so
that's going to be a problem and a
realizes hey I don't have the lock so
it's aware of that because it didn't get
two success messages from the two
clients that it wrote to now B comes
along and it's going to do the following
it's going to say hm I want to grab the
lock also does anyone actually have the
lock let me go ahead and check well the
first thing that it's going to do is go
over to these two nodes over here
because it got unlucky and these are the
two that it happens to be reading from
and it's going to see that one of them
is telling it that a has the lock and
now all of a sudden it thinks that the
lock is taken when it isn't actually in
reality so that is going to be a problem
so in this situation B is going to
incorrectly read that a has the lock now
you might say to yourself well Jordan
why is it that when a realizes that this
right didn't go through it just goes
ahead and reverts this guy over here
right can reach back out to that node
and undo the right well a large
percentage of the time it probably can
but if you know the reason only one of
these rights went through is because the
client itself went down rather than due
to some Network partition over here
how's it going to be revert the right if
it itself is down so uh yeah that's
going to be a problem and again if we
wanted to do anything more than that
these guys would have to communicate
with another uh with one another to
realize to revert rights the point is
you can't rely on asynchronous
communication over the network uh once
something is written there's no
guaranteed way to make sure that we
revert it and as a result we can have
all sorts of data consistency
issues another problem with quorums are
is that they are not linearizable what
does linearizable mean it effectively
means that we can create one cohesive
ordering of all of the rights in our
system when we actually look at them
over time so here's an example where
they are not going to be
linearizable uh and and keep in mind
they have to be linearizable basically
in the moment right during a right I
have to know exactly what came before
something else because that way I can
assign something like a fencing token to
it so that I know uh for a given grab of
the lock uh which person came earlier
and which person came later so let's
imagine the following scenario we've got
a quorum where a cluster of n equal 3 we
want to write to two nodes and we want
to read from two nodes so client a is
going to go ahead and uh right to these
two nodes on the left and it's going to
get the fencing token of one because
they have yet to see any rights
so in this case I'm assuming the fencing
token that you get assigned is basically
the the version number that both of
those nodes see and then you know if you
get two different version numbers from
the nodes that you're getting uh you'll
just take the max of the two cool so
since this is right number one basically
we're going to see a is version one uh a
is version one now let's imagine that a
does what it needs to do and it gives up
the lock so client B comes along and it
wants to grab the lock and now it's
writing to these guys so over here we've
got B is equal to version one because
this guy has seen no rights and then
we've got B is equal to version two now
I can compare the two responses that it
got back from these nodes on successful
rights and say okay two is clearly
higher so let's say I have fencing token
two the next thing that's going to
happen is C comes along because B has
now given up the lock and now C is going
to say okay well here I've got C with
version number two and over here I've
got C with version number two it looks
like my fencing token is number two
that's a problem right there because it
means that within our system we can't
instantly tell which right came first
between C and B because they both have
fencing token number two so if they now
both try and write to S3 at the same
time right let's say B ended up actually
having a process pause due to a garbage
collection so it went down and now all
of a sudden it's writing to S3 with
token 2 they're both writing to S3 with
token 2 we've got a corruption issue and
things are going to fail now I'm sure at
least one of you is is going to argue
with me in the comments about this uh
and so I make this very very small note
on it which I'll cover for about 30
seconds before I confuse myself too much
because you can think about this for
literally an hour if every single node
decided to only accept rights with
version vectors that were up to date
with the current state on that node
maybe we can ensure that we uh basically
you know make all of our rights
linearizable right because then every
right is up to date and so we can
explicitly say that one right is after
another
however what's going to have to happen
then is that every single one of these
nodes is going to have to reject quite a
few more rights therefore leading to
partial failures anyway major tangent
don't worry if you don't understand that
one that much but you're welcome to
think about that sentence as long as you
want cool now let's talk about
distributed consensus because ultimately
this is what we need to build
linearizable rights so what is good
about distributed uh consensus
algorithms well unlike something like
completely synchronous replication
which does technically lead to consensus
but has no fault tolerance distributed
consensus algorithms are fault tolerant
and they allow us to build out
linearizable storage which means we can
quickly figure out uh The Ordering of
people grabbing the lock which is huge
for us so as far as rights go through
I'm going to basically quickly um go
over the raft algorithm again which
we've gone over multiple times but this
is hopefully going to take me sub five
minutes to do so let's imagine we're
writing to our distributed consensus
system typically what we'll have is a
leader we'll have some followers right
typically we'll have uh like three or
five total nodes in this cluster and so
what our leader will do is it'll propose
the right to its followers and uh if it
gets basically a two-phase commit to
both of those followers and if uh a
majority of total nodes in the system uh
approve this right the leader will
commit it right so it really only needs
to hear back from this guy over here and
even if the right to this guy fails it
doesn't matter because it has 2/3
approval uh or majority approval in this
case and as a result we can commit the
right so we're going to commit the right
over to our leader so now there are 101
entries in the log and Sam and this
follow over here there's 101 entries in
the log and this guy who might be a
little bit behind because it's down it
can't progress but that's okay for the
time
being cool step number two is that uh
another nice aspect of Rights in our
distributed consensus algorithm is that
rights will actually backfill nodes that
are behind what does that mean so let's
say we've got some leader again and two
followers on the right over here and
this follower is completely up to date
with the leader and this follower is
behind if the leader goes ahead and
sends a proposal for a right to this
follower this guy will actually reject
that proposal until the leader begins to
actually send more old entries so at
first we're going to say okay I'm
sending you entry 101 this guy is going
to say no we then say oh well I'm
sending you 10 101 now it's still going
to say no
then it's going to say okay well what
about 99 100 and 101 and then now this
guy will say yes please send those to me
during the actual two-phase commit phase
and then you'll get the approval there
so we'll backfill you so what does that
actually mean this gives us a pretty
nice property right here what it means
is that if we have a couple of followers
right A and B let's say this guy is a
this guy is b and a has more entries
than b does in this particular Epoch
right so that an epoch would basically
be for this leader while this leader was
the leader if a has more entries in its
log than b does it means that a contains
all of the rights that b does because it
means that if a has any additional
entries the only way that it could have
gotten those additional entries was if
it also backfilled all of the previous
entries so we know that having more
entries for a particular Epoch of a
leader means that you are literally uh
you have the same exact log as all of
the other followers accept a little bit
more maybe one or two entries
more cool so that brings us basically to
the final step here which is actually
what happens when a leader goes down
because of course uh this is hardware
and it is prone to failure so if a
leader goes down the followers are going
to notice they're basically all
heartbeating one another or they're all
sending heartbeats back and forth to the
leader on an occasional timeout and uh
basically some of them are going to
notice that the leader might be down you
can send these heartbeats at a slightly
differing interval so that we don't have
all of them noticing at the exact same
time cool so what's going to happen when
a follower notices that the leader is
down is it is going to become a
candidate node and it's going to do so
with Epoch plus one so it's going to
take the current leader Epoch number add
one to it and say I'm a candidate for
this next Epoch so let's say we've got a
leader over here Epoch 10 and there are
100 entries in its log for that Epoch
over here this guy all of a sudden after
sending heartbeats and noticing that
they cut out says I think the leaders
down I'm now a candidate for Epoch 11
and by the way I have 99 entries in my
log for this Epoch so what's going to
happen now it's basically going to send
that out to all of the other followers
and all of the other followers are going
to vote on whether it should become the
leader now the criteria for voting is
pretty simple it basically just says in
the last
Epoch note this candidate had 99 entries
I'll vote for you if you had the same
amount of entries or more than me so
this guy who also had 9 entries will say
yes I approve of you as a leader these
two guys on the other hand who both had
100 entries will say ooh sorry about
that bud no I'm not voting for you and
they're both going to vote X now to
become the leader you actually need
approval from a majority of nodes so in
this case this guy would have needed
three yes votes but he actually only got
two so he's not going to be a leader one
of these guys over here will have to
eventually become a candidate and
because they have 100 entries in their
log they will get approval votes from
all of the other followers so the main
idea here is that because of the fact
that um one of the followers uh becomes
a candidate with basically one of the
more up-to-date logs right such an
up-to-date log that uh it's more up to
date than a majority of nodes in the
cluster that actually means that it
contains all the committed rights from
the previous Epoch because all of the
committed rights have gone to at least a
majority of nodes in the cluster and
also keep in mind that we're back
filling them as well so whatever the
last right of that Epoch uh is must have
backfilled at least a majority of nodes
in the cluster and so there should be at
least one node uh that has uh this uh
criteria
satisfied cool again I'm going over this
uh pretty quickly which is why I keep
stuttering you can watch the raft videos
where it should hopefully be a little
bit more clear but the idea is basically
you know whatever the last right that
the leader did before it went down it
must must have gone to two uh a majority
of the nodes and that must mean that a
majority of the nodes were now equally
as up to date as the leader which now
means that one of those majority nodes
can easily become the leader for the
next
Epoch that would be how I would
summarize it so what does this look like
in practice right we have our consensus
system over here with three different
nodes how do we make a distributed lock
out of this well it's pretty simple
you're just proposing rights from the
leader and then those rights go to the
followers and then once they're approved
you can report back to the client that
they've gotten their distributed lock so
we've got client a over here which will
say grab lock okay the leader is going
to receive that message do its two-phase
commit over to its two followers it's
going to receive approval and now that
gets added over here into the
distributed log so once uh we store all
of that on disk what we can also do to
speed up reads a little bit is actually
store the state of all the locks in a
hashmap in memory as well uh which
basically corresponds to what was in the
log that we're Distributing
and then as a result when we make reads
we can just read from memory as opposed
to having to build that state all back
up from the distributed log so it should
be relatively quick cool let's quickly
talk about some other implementation
details so for starters one thing that
we don't want is a bunch of clients just
constantly pulling our distributed
Locking System and say hey is the lock
available yet is it available yet is it
available yet that would be bad because
it's going to add a bunch of unnecessary
load we want to keep this thing fast we
want to use it for a lot of different
servers at once so what we should
instead be doing is using something like
a serers side push right we want to keep
track of all the nodes that are waiting
on a particular lock and when it becomes
available we can actually go ahead and
alert them that the lock has become
available now there is one trick to note
here which is that if we notify all of
them at once we're going to get a
thundering heard see the following
diagram below in step one this guy grabs
the lock in step two he releases the
lock in step three we convey to all
three of these other guys that the lock
is available and all of a sudden now
they're all trying to grab it at the
same time and we've put a bunch of
unnecessary load on our system that we
don't need to put there so how do we
solve a problem like this we can
actually just use a q lock so the way
that we would do that is every single
person who tries to grab a lock we can
actually just put them uh in a queue for
that specific lock such that when the
current person who owns the lock uh
releases it we basically pop them from
the queue we look at the next person who
is next up in the queue and we alert
them via either a long poll or a
websocket or a serers side event that
they are uh ready to go so ultimately
that should keep things looking good of
course once you actually do possess the
lock you want to constantly be sending
heartbeats over to the distributed
locking server so that we can make sure
that uh if we think you're down that we
time out the lock and give it to the
next person in line and so we can do
that by basically just using a websocket
right because the thing about a
websocket here is that uh it's going to
allow us to send all of those pings via
a heartbeat without sending repeat HTTP
headers over and over again which may
actually make this go a little bit
faster and use a little bit less load on
our networking uh
capabilities um so I do write over here
that in theory we could have done
something like a long poll request every
time we request for the lock however it
does feel like a websocket may be good
enough anyway because eventually when
you do get access to that lock you're
going to have to be sending those hard
beats over it
cool the last piece of this puzzle is
actually going to be our diagram so in
step one we've got client a over here
trying to go ahead and establish a
websocket connection with our
distributed locking server this is going
to be the leader and then over here we
have a
follower and another follower whenever
the leader receives such a request it's
going to perform its two-phase commit
over to the followers but again it only
actually needs one out of those two
followers to respond
hence we do have a little bit of fall
tolerance the bigger that we expand this
cluster the slower Things become but at
the same time the more fall tolerance
that we afford ourselves okay so we can
go ahead and uh establish our websocket
connection and since this is the first
one being made we're going to receive a
fencing token of let's say 20 this guy
might do the same thing over here client
B however client a still has the lock so
client B is going to be behind client a
and the que eventually client a is going
to go back over the websocket and say
hey I'm unlocking now I'm good to go
this guy gets removed from the que B is
told via the websocket connection that
it has token 21 and now it can go ahead
and write over in S3 if for whatever
reason a was to try and write again with
its old token 20 that should be rejected
because of the fact that it is smaller
than 21 well guys I hope this all made
sense again just a big synthesis of
single leader replication leaderless
replication distributed consensus
Thundering Herd problems some realtime
uh alerting Frameworks and uh yeah
hopefully it made for a semic cohesive
video anyways I've got to head off thank
you again uh for the big subscriber
Milestone uh I really appreciate all of
you and I will see you in the next one